hi my name is Ian Johnson I'll be
presenting a talk on using IOT and the
Wolfram language in mathematical Evan I
work for Wolfram developing
communication protocols and working with
devices like Arduino and raspberry PI's
about using the built-in channel
framework in Mathematica and so new
features that we're going to be adding 2
to the channel framework and how you can
use it for specifically Internet of
Things applications so let me start the
slideshow ok ok so just overview the
things I'm going to talk about a little
bit on just what the channel framework
is what you can use it for and then on
specifically inner things and then
talking about the mq TD protocol which
is going to be a big thing of interns
and then the specific devices that are
all sitting in front of you so and feel
free to like ask any questions if you
have stuff like that this is kind of
meant to be more of a workshop kind of
talk so you know interactive you play
with devices ask me questions about
stuff so yeah ok so let me make this a
little bit bigger that big enough all
right um so the channel framework is new
in mathematica 11 Igor gave a talk on it
the other day it allows communications
between mathematic and other systems
that might be another mathematica kernel
that might be a device like what's
sitting in front of you it could be a
server like an Amazon lambda or ec2
instance or you know whatever there are
lots of different places that you can
have systems talk to the channel
framework it's what's called a pump sub
mechanism and that's kind of what that
stands for is publix publish-subscribe
and it allows it's a particular model of
communication where you have clients
that all connect to one centralized
server or one centralized thing it might
not necessarily be one server you could
have it like load balance or something
but and then those clients subscribe on
particular topics or channels and then
other clients can send on on those
channels and they'll receive the clients
that are subscribed on those channels
will receive any messages that are
published on those and so it allows for
you know one too many so one publisher
sends out something on a channel and a
bunch of subscribers get it or
one-to-one you know one subscriber gets
something they need one it allows for
lots of different communications
patterns and currently the
implementation in 11.0 uses the HTTP
protocol which is you know works well
for allowing lots of different variety
of systems to connect to it including
you know devices and other programming
languages like JavaScript etc yeah so
that's that's just going to overview of
that yeah so I'm going to explain a
little bit how the HTTP interface works
so that I can contrast that with the
proposed MQTT one so let me just make
sure demo channels going okay so so I'm
going to create this this demo channel
and make it public so you can go to that
that link if I make that into a URL and
open that in the browser so this is just
the web page for that and so using the
rest api for the channel framework you
can send stuff through through the web
browser so i don't know if you all can
see this you'll see the typing at the
top yes oh no whoops sorry forgetting
how that REST API works and so using the
REST API you can send data by using the
send operation and then I don't know to
say cram 1 equals I don't know some
number etc so that get sent to the rest
api and that's how you can send data
through the rest api and then actually I
wasn't listening listen on the channel
so there's no active channel sneer so I
send it and now it shows up here and I
got the I got the message so that's how
that clients can send data to the
channel framework super easy just a
simple rest call now receiving data for
clients is where it gets a little bit
more complicated and that's where we use
what's called HTTP long polling and so
I'll show you what that looks like and
how does have to be mode
okay there we go okay sir so you'll
notice it's a little hard to see cuz the
brow I don't know how to zoom in on the
browser but the page is just loading and
loading it's waiting for a message to be
received and so how HTTP long polling is
is the client makes a connection and
then the server just leaves that
connection open until a message arrives
and then it sends it and so this page
will just continue to load indefinitely
until we send a message so I'm just
going to send that message and so now
you see here the message has you know
been delivered by foot fight by the
server so kind of a disadvantage of
using long polling like this is it means
that you know as soon as you get a
message then you have to reopen a
connection and it gets kind of
complicated managing those connections
and you know handling that asynchronous
task like that and so that's one of the
reasons why we're going to implement a
MQTT method that we'll talk about in a
second but why is the channel framework
very useful for Internet of Things
applications well with internet things
you're going to have a lot of
heterogeneous systems such as you know
maybe you have a Arduino or a raspberry
pi or the devices in front of you you
have lots of different systems that are
you know publishing or like creating
data or maybe they're analyzing it and
you know working on that and you want a
so you have lots of different systems
that operate very differently but you
want a unified way to interact with the
data into control of all of these
devices hence you know using a framework
for that and I think a lot of solutions
to IOT currently really kind of fail at
having a consistent way to control that
and so yeah so any of things it's
important to have remote control of the
devices right you might have you know
hundred thousand sensors out in the
field that you know you never see in our
you know miles away from any actual
person to work on so you know remote
evaluation and remote control is really
important for these these kinds of
devices so this is where the MQTT
protocol comes in MQTT was designed
specifically for devices it was designed
for really lightweight communication
protocol or it was designed as a
lightweight communication protocol I
think some
messages that that are sent over MQTT
can be like two bites whereas with HTTP
you know you have lots of overhead and
it could be I don't know hundreds of
bites just to send you know a simple
hello world message whereas with MQTT
that's like very very minimal there's
very little overhead and so it makes it
very efficient for moving lots of data
and it's also very easy for clients to
implement there it's very easy for
clients interact with it because the
MQTT protocol was designed such that a
majority of the load processing is put
on the server side rather than the
client side so that's why you can have
simple little clients like the one
sitting in front of you or even simpler
smaller ones interact with m qg systems
because they're so you know because it's
such a lightweight protocol again m qg t
is pub/sub and in future versions of
mathematical you'll be able to interface
with MQTT networks using using the
channel framework and so the same
functions that you know channel sends
channel listen those wall have analogous
effects on interfacing with with MQTT
networks and yeah like I said it's it's
a very popular protocol and there are
lots of client and server software
available for it mosquito is one of
those that's written in C there's vern
mq there's RabbitMQ there's all sorts of
server and client software for this okay
so now what's sitting in front of you so
I'm going to exit full screen for a
second so what's sitting in front of you
I also have one up here there's a few
different parts to this the first thing
the main thing is this chip here which
is called the esp8266 it's a simple
little chip that connects over Wi-Fi and
has digital pins that can do spi
interface that can do I to see and so I
can communicate with other sensors you
might have that you need to interface
with and then I have this little chip
right here is an analog to digital
converter because the the ESP only has
one analog channel but on the joystick
over here I have the you know two analog
channels 14 x and y so in just a second
when
you know I start having you all you know
play with advices and move the thing
around that you'll notice that the
joystick is a little wobbly so be
careful with it I guess and if the red
light ever goes off that means it
disconnected from the network so just
try unplugging it plug it back in so
yeah so some of the devices i unplugged
just so that the battery doesn't wear
out because the batteries are like last
about an hour or something approximately
so trying to trying to save battery on
that but yeah the other thing about the
esp8266 is that you can program it with
the Arduino IDE which is you know a big
boon because there's lots of software
that people write for the Arduino very
popular and yeah so okay so all of these
devices you have here are connected to a
router I have up here and they're
connected by MQTT and they're sending
the value of their joysticks and they're
also listening on a value or on a
channel for the LEDs on each of them so
you'll see there's also you know an LED
separate from the red LED the red LED is
like Wi-Fi and the separate one will be
individually controllable so this will
be an example of you know you have
devices out there they're sending
producing data if they're also listening
on stuff so i'll show how that works so
so actually each device is publishing
its joystick values on two channels one
individual to the specific client like
the all these clients have you you IDs
and they're publishing their own value
on their own channel and then there's
also a global channel that all of them
are publishing on so in a second I'll
listen to individual ones I'll listen to
the one specifically on up here that I
have and then you know I can listen to a
specific one out there but then I can
also listen to all of them because
they're sending on a global channel so
yeah that's that's that all these you
know I know I collected to include like
a parts list for this but all of this
was like I think under fifteen dollars I
think for all the parts here um you know
buying in bulk etc so yeah so these ESP
82 82 66 ships are pretty pretty cheap
and accept
well here okay okay yeah so let me load
this up yeah so so the joystick is being
put on both the joystick channel as well
as each client has a uuid I'm going to
go back to full screen here here view
okay so the the functions i'm showing
you our will be the exact same as the
general framework functions just to
avoid because it's like an experimental
version they're all prefixed with NQ GT
just so that I avoid you know clobbering
the same names so here we can look at
I'll get rid of this short so we can use
fine channels to find all of the
channels that are currently being you
know processed here and so you can see
all of these joystick channels you know
I don't know which you but one that's
one of these devices out here as that
you ID etc so there's all these channels
you know we can listen on one of them
the Eid of the 1i have up here the eid
is just master just like know which one
it is so we can listen on that if it
wants to cooperate yeah so I'll quick
actually I'm going to click click the
colonel
so it seems to be
it's probably why
okay one more time restarting the server
okay there we go so now we're listening
on on master / joystick which is the one
that's being published here we can do a
dynamic of that so now if i switch back
so you can see yes so that's the values
being updated dynamically so if i move
joystick over it's just being published
one a second so it's a little little
slow to update but you know you can see
move around as I move the joystick
around works all well and good and then
this looks a little ugly cuz it's all
side like that but we can easily make a
make a plot of this so the with the
listener you can get a data set of the
data so there's all the data and there's
there's some metadata as well included
with this you know we have the message
which is the actual data a timestamp
what topic it's on and then there's a
few things a few metadata things here so
we can make a dynamic plot of this so
you see it moves and then buy just the
joystick here you know you'll see you'll
see it move around so so that's on this
specific one and I could go and listen
on you know one of the ones out there I
have all the UU IDs here on each of the
the bread boards in front of you
underneath where the cable is there's a
little letter written in sharpie on the
front of the bread board underneath the
cable so for first I'll show so when I
send a message on the master LED you'll
see that led comes on like that and then
if I turn and turn it off by sending a
zero I'll turn off so these are the you
IDs and Jason what letter is yours on
x alright there we go let's turn exxon
deadly do you come on it looks like yep
so we can turn it off etc and then if I
want to turn all of them on I just send
message on all of those looks like
couple got disconnected there but for
the most part all work and then I can
turn them all off from up here so that's
how you could do remote control right
each individual client is listening on a
particular channel that you can use to
control that particular one and you know
it's easy from the woman language to
control all of them at once or control
individual ones you know you can make
buttons you could make whatever kind of
manipulates or graphical user interfaces
you want but but yeah so so that's
that's kind of how you do that now all
of the all of these are also publishing
on the global channel the joystick
channel so i can click actually before I
do this I'm going to turn the other
listener off just so I cook light
just because like all of this all the
server stuff is running on my machine
instead of the more I can let my she not
machine off the hook the better okay so
so I'm going to quick listen on its
global channel you can see it's growing
pretty quickly because each of these are
publishing at 11 a second so now I try
and do this dynamic hopefully hopefully
can handle it so you can see them all
move around so now if everybody on the
one in front of them like pushes the
joystick to the left we can see you know
try and see the aggregate of of all
these go down some of them nobody's in
front of so nobody can do that but but
yeah so so this isn't you know you're
producing data it's showing up here and
and yeah we're live plotting it so this
is all live generated data I'm going to
shut this off for a second and yeah and
we still have the specific values up
here so so yeah I'm going to stop
listening on this for a second okay so
let's talk about so this is the arduino
sketch that all of these are running
zoom in a little bit too
okay so this is a simple sketch that the
Arduino is are running these are some
constants I don't remember which one
which specific devices is out here set
up some constants and then the setup
function we just connect to spi because
we need to connect to SBI for the
analog-to-digital chips we set up but we
connect to Wi-Fi first at the top and
then turn turn the pins off just because
that's their the Wi-Fi you know there's
real easy Wi-Fi libraries available for
this device so you should do Wi-Fi begin
with the SSID and the password and then
wait and tell it gets connected so so
the Arduino software can program this
device you can use the Arduino software
originally the Arduino software came out
to program just the Arduino board but
because Arduino software and Arduino
device got really really popular people
started expanding the software so that
it can upload to other stuff so like for
example on my machine these are all the
different boards that I can program
because I've installed a bunch of
different stuff so there's like all
these chip get stuff you know all sorts
of like random boards so you can use the
same software the same Arduino software
to program a bunch of different devices
and that's what I've done for this and
I'm just kind of walking through the
sketch that this is running so this this
year's is the callback function that's
called you can ignore these debugging
print statements but basically we just
check to see you know the if the the
message we got is that the client led
topic if it is then look at the payload
which is the message that was sent and
messages currently they're being sent as
JSON that not Jason but Jason is in the
format and luckily for us in the JSON
format 0 and 1 is just the character 0
and the character one so we can just
switch and see what what is and turn it
on or off you you can also send more
arbitrary like complicated expressions
just that in you know in this case 0 1
seem to fit but when you send data
from so when I do like you know I think
you might have noticed this before but
when I did if i send no not listen
Sensei to hello channel you know I can
type whatever arbitrary expression I
want to like if I just do something like
that I guess that channel doesn't exist
here i'll just send it to master
joystick I guess nobody's listening but
you know you can send whatever arbitrary
expression you want so if i wanted to
send like I don't know an image or
something like an image that's kind of
dark you know I take this or mathematica
crush but I was probably asking you too
much to do all this and take a picture
you know one or the other probably but
whatever I was getting at is that we
encode expressions when we send them so
you can send whatever arbitrary
expression you want and this is a
question yeah so so in this case I
specifically a better way to do it than
how I did it because how i did it is i
just ran a little script that generated
30 different sketches each of which the
only lines changed where this uuid and
so the uid is hard-coded and you can see
these are the these are like the urls
kind of that that they're publishing on
and listening on that was not the
smartest thing for me to do because
originally my sketch had a typo in it
and so they were all sending on the
wrong or they couldn't connect to the
Wi-Fi network and so I then had to
reupload the sketch to all 30 of them
again so a better way to do it I think
would be to have each of these like
connect to a server and like get their
uid dynamically so that they can all
have the same sketch and and I don't
have to re-upload it 30 times when I
make a mistake but
yeah yeah you can generate you ID from
the mac address some of these devices
though are kind of weird with their mac
address handling like sometimes I show
up is the same mac address yeah I mean
yeah there's a lots of different ways
you could generate a UID
programmatically this was just the
simplest way that I saw so that's what I
went with oh but but getting back so see
ya thats that's what when we get a
message that's what we do we see if at 0
with its 1 and right to it and and you
can see so we just have that one
subscribe function and then to ensure
that that gets called every time that we
get a message all we have to do is
connect or subscribe will connect to the
server obviously and then call this
function subscribe which is like a
standard function that you know you'd
call with any MQTT client library and
then in this case we just call client
loop right we don't have to worry about
long polling we don't have to worry
about like checking to see when messages
are done the library takes care of it
all for us and it's a very nice easy
easy way to connect to to the device and
actually you see like how we're sending
the data is I just hard coded in the
JSON and imprinting the values when we
read from the ADC so and then I have a
delay in there these devices are
actually pretty fast when I had one
device publishing without any delay it
was sending like 200 messages a second
which x 30 my laptop can't handle that
so see I just have a little delay in
there and then this this ADC read
function is just a some simple spi code
to read from the ADC but ok go back to
yeah yeah I can do so yeah yeah yeah so
what that is that come in how I have it
set up is just for the LED but you could
certainly have that for other devices
right a lot of times sensors that you'll
attach to have like a low power mode and
you could certainly send a message to
devices and tell them like oh go all
into low power mode etc let me get back
in here yep yep lots of people do that
lots of people have especially for a
smart or like smart connected homes as
they'll have like one Raspberry Pi
that's running an MQTT server and
connected to the network and then
they'll have a bunch of cheaper devices
like what you have in front of you that
are like five six dollars connected
around the house that connect via Wi-Fi
so that's that's this pretty comment
I've seen that done a lot because you
know you you have the Raspberry Pi
running you're more complicated software
you know it's still not like a full full
white server but for smart home stuff
it's usually enough and then you have
smaller cheaper more power efficient
devices out attached to your sensors
that way yeah so that's what I was just
talking about showing all this and
that's when I listen to all that yeah ok
so there are other devices that we can
connect one of which is the Arduino Eun
that I have with the uni with 11.1 or
11.0 so on the shipping version of 11
you have you can attach an Arduino Eun
and deploy a function that uses the
Yoon's Wi-Fi capabilities to correct
connector directly to the channel
framework so you just plug it in and
dudes like device open of the Arduino
Eun and then device configure of like I
don't remember the exact syntax well
that's actually there's a guide in the
documentation center I'll do this
well specifically we start with data
drop but oh yeah oh that's where it is
right yeah in the applications devices
here we go yeah yeah so all you have to
do you just open up a connection to the
device using device open and then you
can upload this little function which so
so this specifically what we're doing
here is uploading what's called the boot
function to the Arduino so that as soon
as the Arduino turns on it runs your
little function come in here we have
special functions coded for a channel
sinned so this sends to the sentence of
whatever channel you specify the value
of pins a 0 a 1 and a 2 right so that's
a pretty easy way to deploy stuff out
out in the field today using the are do
it or do we know Yoon to send data but
again listening is is a more complicated
manner because of how the HTTP server
currently works which is why we're going
to expand it to em qtd but yeah so there
are other devices like the Arduino Yoon
Raspberry Pi is another example of a
device that you could connect and and
use this for yeah there are lots of
other like smaller devices the advantage
like in inner things a lot a lot of
times you'll see people have you know
lots of different kinds of devices and
so they're going to connect to the
server and perhaps different ways but
the point is that when use the channel
framework and use mathematical Wolfram
language with this you get a unified way
to access that data and control those
devices which makes it greatly
simplifies applications so this that
concludes like the set part of my talk
but this is a workshop so I'm going to
open up to any questions or you know if
you want to see demos of anything else
done with all the devices in the room
you know for you to free to do that for
you
yeah yep as part of the channel
framework yes so so what what we what
we're going to do is when we have the
ability in the channel framework to use
MQTT as a method is we're going to be
able to connect it to your own MQTT
network so if you have one set up behind
you know your company firewall or you're
on your own home network or something
that's not live to the internet you will
be able to connect it to that mq TD
server and and use the same set of
functions just on that local version is
how we're anticipating that again not
sure if that will be a like 11.1 or 11.2
but that's functionality that we would
like very much like to bring and that
will will be coming so there there some
yeah so so in the mq TD protocol there
are some features that we're not taking
advantage of with the channel framework
as to whether or not we'll expose those
underlying the channel framework is a
package that literally just does the mpg
protocol and so you'll be able to like
create your own clients and do your own
straight MQTT stuff but that's like
internal stuff so with with the channel
framework like layer of those for all
those functions some of the mq g
protocol will be exposed but some stuff
like like retained messages and other
aspects of the protocol might not might
not be there so so a common thing that
people use it for is because it's inert
so the thing about the Arduino units
special is it has a normal Arduino chip
and then this big silver chip is a mips
processor that's running I think open
wrt I don't remember the exact operating
system but it's running like router
software so it can both connect to Wi-Fi
but it can also act as a Wi-Fi host and
it can host its own Wi-Fi network so
sometimes people use that
and have this running little so some
people run MQTT servers on Arduino you
and then they have other devices connect
to that but yeah because the dual
processor nature of this makes it very
helpful for for projects where you need
that yep yep it as Ethernet yeah it has
both Wi-Fi in the Ethernet port yeah and
an Arduino union is supported through
Mathematica so you can plug it into
mathematica and deploy you know your
functions that send to the channel or or
today to drop as well we have support
for that another question so so yeah so
the timestamp is one the message is
received on the machine because there's
we do talk there is a timestamp that
happens on the server but just for the
purpose of this I was just using the
timestamp of when it's received because
there's no real good way of knowing when
it was sent by the client right because
it might go through routers and like you
know you never ridden but but yes in
this particular instance it was being
time stamped on on the client when
mathematica received it but for for the
current for the production channel for
framework version it's time stamped on
the server just on this local version
that i was running is time stamp on the
machine but to answer your question yeah
sure so the youn updating the unit is
something that happens a lot less
frequently because it's running like
basically router firmware like an open
version of router firmware and sometimes
you do want to update it and actually
when you log into the Yoon there's a
nice thing that you just click check for
updates update available click download
and then and then it shows like one of
those bars like do not restart it during
this you know or else you'll brick the
device or something but I don't the
firmware on on the firmware on the
router or the youn weather isn't meant
to be I sorry the firmware on the MIPS
processor on the Union isn't meant to be
updated very frequently that's like
supposed to not change very much yeah
exactly yeah because you could break the
device when you do that then you have a
very nice paper paperweight question
as long as it's reachable from the
network so in this case all of these are
sending all of the data that's being
sent here actually is never touching the
internet it just goes to this router and
then my machine is on the router running
the server so it just goes here so it
just has to be accessible through the
network so these devices could be set up
to the go all the way out to the art
public channel framework servers and
then come back to my machine it's just a
matter of how your network is set up in
this case they're not going out to the
internet that was also by design because
the internet connection here is like
pretty unreliable and so here just it
all goes straight to my device yeah
exactly securable and that's that's
something that you know I know a lot of
companies and a lot of businesses want
to be able to do is have control of and
that's why we want to have the ability
for a local I'm qgu broker or not
necessary local but like on your own
internal network you can be running your
own MTG broker and you know have plugins
or you know whatever you want set up and
still use channel framework for all that
data but it just never touches our cloud
or anybody's called because it stays on
your own thing but again thats future
functionality that is not in 11.0 yet so
any more questions yeah
yup so sorry that I'll go back to the
previous page the the micro fought the
processor on here is called esp8266 this
specific one is made by like some
chinese company like H I let go I forget
I can pull up the Amazon is that there
shouldn't be a notebook on battle site
for this talk because the the mq TD
features and stuff here is still like
pre-release tough and so we're not
releasing good the notebook i have has a
bunch of code that is all running this
that we don't we're not going to release
if people want i can remove all of that
and just include like the bear notebook
with just these diagrams and stuff 11th
i'm not sure i can upload a notebook
that that has the code removed if you'd
like but i'm not sure what notebook you
have it might be a different talk
because I suppose I specifically told
them I wasn't uploading a notebook so
there shouldn't be a notebook there if
there is it could be yeah it could be
from the other one the vernis a talk
yeah sure oh yeah I'll remove the code
from the notebook and upload it so that
you can see the rest of the stuff yep
there's actually a newer newer version
of the chip this trip has just Wi-Fi but
the company Express if that makes these
just released a newer version that's
like same price point but also at
bluetooth so if you're interested in it
you know you can get a better version
than the one i have here
sure yeah yeah let me let me load it up
okay uh I don't know um what was the one
liner ah I don't know how you do that
from was it like I would use the data
here I well I suppose we could do like a
moving average of like where it is and
then try and get everybody to like move
it somewhere yeah let me all right so
let's grab yeah I know I know I know is
somebody could go around and unplug the
ones that if they wanted join
to another join
so yeah it looks like they're almost
exactly in the center oh let's divide
this by let's just make this note my
disk
I'll use
forget radius second
well
so we want to show the axes figure what
that option is for graphics to show
access it was showing up is red when I
did that yes oh there we go okay there
we go let's make this a little bit
oh yeah
yeah this I probably shouldn't add that
dynamic running at the same time
let's try this again
joystiq let me delete that dynamic
okay so there's all the values again
oh yeah sure
so we do envy yous
do you know you hit the the range on a
graphics I assume there's an option for
that that work even though it's not a
plot there you go let's do the angolan
why oh yeah there we go okay so save the
notebooks we get this and then let's
wrap this all and dynamic and hope and
pray that the front end in you to work
okay so okay so does everybody have have
the joystick all right let's all move it
to the right doesn't appear to be moving
very much moving very slowly hear what I
i I'm going to take like the last 30
values like rather than because it's
it's thickens going to continue to
average with like you know all the time
that it spends not doing anything so up
for front-end alright one more try I
save the notebook so we have their code
one more try
oh yeah you're saying yeah full screen
makes it not happy i forgot
okay so if i take first night let's try
yeah let's just try 30 and reverse again
I really wish up to of a negative number
worked that would save me so much time
do that all the time I suppose but I
typing double brackets is this okay all
right let's make this dynamic again all
right so now if we all push it to the
left oh it's moving look at that
although I forget which yeah i think the
left might actually be down yeah yeah so
i guess if you rotate it 90 degrees and
then move it right but well yeah this is
like one of those like games call
there's something on twitch that was
like this yeah exactly where they'd like
average all of like a bunch of people on
the internet choosing a thing we made
that in mathematica feel pretty proud of
ourselves so so yeah any any other
questions or anything else you want to
see demonstrated with this all we have
all the devices here yeah yeah I think
so I'm excited for it so
wait get this ready so the channel
framework is all up and ready you can
use the channel framework the only thing
the part of my talk that that as
demonstrating is the MQTT aspect so you
can do this exact same demo at home you
just can't use MQTT and so instead of
like using MQTT protocol on the device
so where I have all this Arduino code
where I like like this where I like
connect and then subscribe instead of
doing that you would make HTTP requests
and so you'd like send values using you
do like it like like a get request it
work with the same hardware yeah exactly
because because the are the only
difference between doing it via MQTT
like I have and doing if I HTTP is with
HTTP like i mentioned listening is a
little bit more complicated due to long
polling but all you need to do in the
code is select like here in a browser we
could do we could all do the same thing
using our browsers if we do using the
URL of the channel that you're
interested in so in this case would be
like / joystick or something and then
you do parentheses end because it's a
REST API and then whatever you know
whatever a DC 1 equals 500 or whatever
number you can do that from the browser
because the data that was being sent by
MQTT you can send it via the browser too
so it's just going to a certain like web
page and providing parameters
so that device communicates with the
server right now through MQTT protocol
if you wanted to run this at home you
take the device and instead of using the
mq TD protocol use HTTP right yeah yeah
yeah yeah this this sketch which I'm
going to put the sketch on the path full
page I didn't quite get a chance to do
that but this sketch you would just
change stuff so right here this line
that says m QD client publish that value
screen instead that would be something
like I don't know like HTTP client dot
you know I don't know get and then you
would include like the URL like this as
it as a string so do you do something
like that does that make sense it's two
different ways of communicating with the
server oh so this this Arduino software
I've pulled up here here if I was going
to change this to use HTTP I just you
know change a few lines of the code and
then plug in the device like I have like
plugging in via computer over USB and
then upload it through the Arduino
software IDE yep yep yep and you can go
online the rdy any IDE is like free you
can find it if you search for arduino
ide esp8266 you can find the you know a
tutorial that walks you through how to
program at using arduino ide so yeah
alright well I think we're that's for 20
so got ten minutes left if anybody has
any questions
alright well thanks for coming to the
nope sorry 11.1 or 11.2 yeah we've
probably 11 point of view so soonish
right thanks